During world Wari.
Most women were doing their duty on the home front by working in factories and
looking after the future generations of their respective nations.
But there was 1 24 year old Ukrainian woman named Lud Miller pav.
Chenko she wasn't about to let Nazi Germany take over her beloved USSR with
309 confirmed kills Lud Miller pav Chenga became the most successful female,
neither in all of history.
Lu Miller BEOV vote was born on July the 12th, 1916 and biller in Ukraine.
This was just a year before the BOL revolution.
When the Russian em empire was transformed into the USSR,
she was raised in a world where people had a zealous enthusiasm for communism
and women.
They were beginning to enjoy the benefits of the feminist ideals that came along
with it.
Her mother was a school teacher and her father was a factory worker in St.
Petersburg. During the Bolick revolution,
he also fought for the red army during the Russian civil, what?
After a few years,
her father worked his way up to an executive position that required the family
to move to a different town. Every year.
This meant that every year she was forced to start over in a new school.
As a young girl,
Belo was considered to be a bit of a tomboy because she preferred to play
outside with the boys. Since she spent her whole life playing sports outside,
she was very athletic and could do anything thing that a boy could do when she
was 14 years old, her family moved to the city of key.
She was trying to make new friends.
One of the boys in town was constantly bragging that he was a real sharp
shooter,
annoyed his arrogance below the thought to herself that she could shoot as well
as any boy could. So she signed up to be a part of a local shooting club.
And here's the thing. She was absolutely right.
She had the natural talent and determination to prove that she could succeed at
this male dominated sport. Soon enough,
she began to win medals at all sorts of marksmanship competitions.
One day she went to the carnival with her friends.
There was a booth set up with 12 different targets.
If you hit one target with the gun, you got a prize Luman up,
paid for 15 bullets and knocked down all of the 12 targets. She said,
the man who ran the place turned pale with alarm and astonishment as the
unfastened one prize after another and piled them up beside me,
after letting him hand me the 12th,
I felt sorry for him and gave him back all the prizes. As a teenager,
she began working at the Kiev arsenal factory. They made weapons.
So she was very literally learning the ins and outs of guns.
And as time went on, she became an expert in firearms,
into skillset improved exponentially, eager to complete her education,
LA Miller finished school a year and a half earlier than her peers.
But the time it wasn't uncommon for young women to drop out of school at an
early age in favor of working this, she was determined to go to college already,
a high school graduate. She married a young man named Alex Pavlo Chen.
The age of 16. They had a son together named Rola young women in Russia.
They were expected to get married and start having children at an early age.
So this wasn't strange or scandalous in any way.
And unlike in other parts of the world,
the USSR had pride in their women working full time and also raising a family.
It was rare for women to become a stay at home.
Mom who focused on her own children and her husband's needs.
The only way they were able to accomplish this was to have the mindset that it
takes a village to raise a child.
Everyone took turns looking after the children of the community. Of course,
this was all part of larger communist ideal that the country,
as a whole was more important than your individual family, Lud, Miller, Pavlo,
Chanka.
She wanted more in her life than just raising her son and working in the AOR
factory. She wanted an education and she wanted a career.
This ultimately led her to getting a divorce,
even though she and Alexa were buried for a short while.
Lud Miller continued to use her new last Chenko after getting her divorce
finalized,
she became a history major at Kiev university and planned to become a teacher
before the ward,
the upper management in the arsenal factory recommended her for a position in
the military engineering school.
But she declines because she wasn't interested in warfare.
She was about to finish her bachelor's degree and she planned to go on to earn
her masters. But before she could complete her education,
the Nazis bombed her school
In the summer of 1941,
the Nazis invaded the Soviet union with their plan called operation Barbara
Rosa, the battle of Kiev,
it brought the war very literally to li Miller's front door.
The Nazis attacks from both the north and the making this the largest
encirclement in all of history. But Miller later said of these Nazi attacks.
You do not know what it is to have bombs falling all around you.
You do not know what it is to see babies murdered women and girls ravished by
Hitler ride beasts.
You do not know what it is to find the chard bodies of your own comrades burns
and torture beyond recognition to see rows of brave, fine people.
People you knew hanging along the roadside after witnessing
all of the death and destruction brought to home by the Germans,
she was ready and willing to set aside her dreams of becoming a teacher in order
to kill some Nazis. She was 24 years old when she enlisted in the Soviet army.
At first, she was actually denied because she was a woman in 1941.
There was a push for women to replace their husband's jobs in the factories and
help secure the home front. While the men went off to war,
the USS R would eventually begin recruiting women on a more regular basis in
1942.
But pav Chenko was one of the rare ladies who took the initiative to show up
without being asked. Men were accepted into the army straight away, of course,
but as a lady,
she needed to prove that she was actually capable of fighting and killing some
Nazis. She was prepared for their doubt though, because she brought with her,
her marksmanship medals. After seeing her skill, they allowed her to enlist,
but the trials in proving herself, they were far from over the Russians,
sent her to study at a sniper school. They would,
if a eventually be and all women's sniper school established in 1942,
but lame pav, Chanka.
She volunteered so early that she had to go to one that was filled with men,
the officers, they began to bully her. And during her initiation,
she was told that she had to kill two German soldiers who were standing in an
open field. If she failed,
she was no longer allowed to be a sniper and she'd have to return home asking
someone to do this.
Especially a rookie was nearly an impossible feat during world war II.
The average sniper needed multiple bullets to kill someone. Not only that,
but the moment one soldier was shot and killed.
The second would immediately know to take cover and drop to the grounds or
indeed cute bag.
This was also the first time that Laila Chenko would've killed another human
being, but she did not complain.
She took a deep breath and calmly killed both Nazis with two quick
headshots, her reign. It was perfect, but her cover was blown.
The enemy began to fire in her direction. She said, I have to admit,
I was scared in my first real baptism of fire.
I was in range of hot German fire.
As I called out to our machine gun to cover me with return fire and save me as
terrifying as that day must have been. She officially passed the test.
She became a sniper in the red army.
The SGE of Odessa lasted from the 8th of August to the 16th of October,
1941. During those two months of fighting the Nazis Leila Pavlo Chanka achieved
187 confirmed kills. Now at the time also Sophia snipers used a MOS,
NAS M 91 slash 30,
and many of them kept track of their confirmed kills by cutting a notch into the
butt of their gun with a knife.
One of the many reasons why P Chanka was so successful at being a sniper was
that she had a deep seated hatred for the Nazi season.
No longer saw them as human beings. Hatred did not come to us all at once.
We are a peace loving people and we had to learn to hate,
but fierce hatred rose within us. After we saw with our own eyes,
what the Hitler beasts could do. Now,
we hate the enemy too much to fear him once a laab was hiding inside of a tree
covered with leaves,
an enemy soldier figured out where she was and began to shoot the tree.
Knowing that her cover was blown. She purposefully fell,
even though she was still alive. Once she hit the ground,
she laid still and played dead.
The battle continued to rage on around her and the bodies of her comrades fell
feet away from her.
She waited until night to finally stand up and sneak her way back to camp.
Her comrades looked at her like they were seeing her ghost.
Everyone at this point began calling her lady death.
This near death experience only made her more cautious and she thought harder
about every single strategy. She invented tactics to distract the Nazis.
Some of these tricks included things like brightly covered scarves on plants,
but after she used one of these tricks, a few times,
she knew that it was time to try something new. Next was the battle of Severto,
where she killed an additional 70 soldiers bringing a new total kill count to
257.
Her superior offices knew the Chenko was needed as a counter sniper,
which means that she was assigned to take out other snipers,
which was significantly more difficult than bringing down regular soldiers.
During this time being a counter SNI,
she would have to stay in a hiding spot without moving for as long as it took to
take down the other Snyders. On average,
it would take her 15 to 20 hours to spot and kill the enemy.
SNY Pavlo Chenko said the one of the most common tricks that the Germans tried
to use was to toss a tin can, which glistened in the sun.
If she shot at the can, it would give her position away.
Another comment tactic was to use a dummy, wearing a German uniform,
hidden in the bushes.
Another soldier even brought a pet cat with him and threw it out into the open
as if to give her a false sense of security.
Once they exhausted their long list of politics,
the sniper thought the coast was clear.
He would stand up and that's the moment when she would shoot him.
But there was at least one German sniper that took three days of laying still in
a hiding spot without any food or water.
She went head-to-head with enemy snipers 36 times.
And she always came out victorious.
There was one particular battle where all of the senior officers had been killed
with everyone being of equal rank. No one knew what to do.
There was no one willing to step up and take over, but pad Cheka.
She took the initiative and started shouting a plan on what to do next.
At first, some of the men hesitated to listen to her until one of them yelled,
cos look at this woman pad Cheka as the balls of a man,
that comments was enough to snap them out of their fear.
And the men agreed to go with her because of her, they out alive.
But of course the war wasn't just filled with triumph moments like this,
she witnessed truly gruesome things that would haunt her for the rest of her
life. One such moment was when the Nazis had occupied a town called soft course,
Ika just outside of ESSA.
The red army managed to defend the city and the soldiers began to check in on
the civilians and give medical attention to those in neat.
The Miller P Cheka was one of soldiers who rushed to the local retirement home
to make sure that the elderly people were all right.
It was early morning and the sun was just rising.
And we went in to set the people there free,
but what we found were the bodies of 108 people shot and tortured slashed
pieces, 108 people, all of them, mold and LLL,
and so depraved to those Hitler rights that the old women had all been with.
Every passing moment Cheka was finding more and more motivation to keep on
killing Nazis. Eventually her kill counter was raised to a total of 309,
not counting the first two men that should killed more and more people began to
whisper stories about Chenga.
She began rising in the ranks of the red army and became left tens.
After a while that Miller Pavlo Chenga had a reputation receded her.
When the Germans knew that she was cross enemy lines,
they would shout that she was going to be cut into 309 pieces.
Other times that Germans would offer to give her chocolate if she came over to
their side, but this didn't rattle her nerves. If anything, it only amused her.
She knew that if they were calling her by name,
it meant that they knew who she was a were truly terrified of her.
The feeling I have after killing a Nazi is the feeling of a hunter who has
killed a beast of prey. Every time my bullet fell a Nazi,
I have the feeling that I've saved lives.
Now they say that all is fair in love and war, but for Miller paver,
Cheka she got a bit of both.
She fell in love with the fellow sniper named Sergeant major Lynn.
It could sang, unfortunately we don't know much about this man,
because there are very few records that exist outside of her.
Very brief mention of him in her speeches. They were married during the war,
but tragically Chenko. He was killed in the line of duty.
Chenko herself was shot four times in the course of the war.
Shrapnel was also scattered all over her body. And yet she continued to fight,
but they reached a point when there was so much shrapnel in her body that her
health was on the rapid decline and she had to be rushed to the hospital.
She was honorably discharged back to her home in the Ukraine and became reunited
with her son. However, without her beloved Senco,
there was a whole missing in her heart.
She couldn't settle down and start her life for her, the war, it wasn't over.
And her opportunity to fight Nazis in another way was just around the corner
For years, the United States, it refrains from getting involved in world war II,
but in 1941, a Japanese attacked Pearl Harbor,
the United States sent soldiers to fight the Japanese,
but they didn't send any of them into Europe for a few more years.
Joseph Stalin reached out to Franklin Delano Roosevelt for help in what they
called the second front. However,
it was hard enough to convince Americans to sacrifice their lives in the first
place. And they desperately needed public approval.
Before Roosevelt began to troops to Europe,
one of their strategies was to have Miller Pavlo.
Cheka go on an American tour to speak to audiences about her story.
Roosevelt believed that by seeing that even women were fighting in Russia,
that this would actually hurt the pride of American men and make them feel more
inclined to go to war the Miller Pavlo Cheka.
She traveled to the United States in 1942,
but instead of respecting her and amazing accomplishments, American reporters,
they were quite rude. They asked her why she did not wear makeup or styler hair.
Another asked how she felt about the boxy military uniform that made her look
fat. One writer, the Washington post,
Melvin Lindsay even wrote that Pavlo Chenko should have won makeup on the Baso
field in her article that said,
isn't it a part of military philosophy that an efficient warrior takes pride in
his appearance. Isn't Jon Neva always pictured in beautiful and shining armor.
That's ridiculous. As it sounds,
Valchenko had to make a public statement to the American media that when you are
getting shot out,
you don't exactly have time to worry about powdering your nose.
First lady ele Roosevelt was on the tour as well. And she was quietly seeth.
When she saw what was going on with all of this pressure being put on her
shoulders Cheka felt understandably awkward during her speeches.
She could not speak English.
So a Russian translator was there to help out after the first speech Mrs.
Roosevelt decided to take that Miller Cheka under her wing.
She gave her advice on public speaking,
as well as learning how to ignore the reporters and their outlandish questions.
During the talk,
they traveled to a total of 43 different states as time went on,
Cheka got more and more comfortable in front of the crowd.
And she learned to smile and stand with ease and confidence.
As she told her inspiring stories.
When reporters asked her condescending questions,
she was ready with witty answers.
I can never necessarily expect these two people to become close ele Roosevelt's
and PEBLO Chen. They became very good friends and they were sad to say goodbye.
After her American tour, PEBLO Chen returned home to the Ukraine,
photographs and excerpts from her life story.
They were printed in newspapers all over the world,
and she became a national symbol of women in the USSR. In 1943,
she was honored by being featured on a Russian postage stamp.
Even though she is one of the most celebrated female gunners Lu Miller Pavlo
Chenko was far from being the only hero of the red army,
a woman named Nina on a over factory job to pan a machine gun.
She became known as anchor the machine gunner despite her success.
She was killed early on in the war and Postly awarded a medal,
naming her a hero of the Soviet union.
There was also another accomplished female sniper named Rosa Shaina,
who was nicknamed the unseen terror of pressure.
After world Wari was over the cold war. Again, the Soviets,
they were no longer friends of the Americans. 15 years after meeting her.
I know Roosevelt could not help, but wonder what happened to the Miller pav,
Chanka. They had been dear friends during the tour,
but she had no way of contacting her from behind the iron curtain.
Mrs. Roosevelt traveled to the Soviet union Bishop. Of course,
she got a lot of pushback from the government. It was incredibly difficult.
Find out where PLO Cheka actually lived.
When a Roosevelt eventually did find a Pavlo.
Cheka had returned to her hometown and finished her studies at the newly rebuilt
ke university. She finished her master's degree in history.
Instead of becoming a teacher,
she was given the more prestigious job as a research specialist for the Soviet
Navy.
She had gone married again and was living a happy and comfortable li Miller
Pavlo Chanka passed away in 1974 when she was 58 years old.
But the story of her bravery has lived on in 2015,
a Russian movie called the battle for Salvato was made based on her story even
to this day.
No other woman has been able to surpass her kill count of 309 cementing her as
the greatest female sniper in history. So I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did, please do gives the thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like this several times a week.
So hit that subscribe button and the notification belt,
if you want to actually find out when we put these videos out,
other videos linked to on the screen now from the archives.
And if you're looking for even more from me,
check out my other channel called today,
I found out you'll find a link to that below and as always,
thank you for watching.